you guys do it right they're doing good
first of all congrats on having your
your series picked up by Netflix that's
awesome thank you um talk a little bit
about the how it all came together and
what was it that you wanted to make sure
that accomplished in the move to that
medium of television I think what we
wanted to get accomplished in the move
was really to see these characters
expanded and the story told in in longer
form so you get more out of it and get
to spend more time with the characters
yeah and I don't know expand everything
the world visually our audience you know
we're gonna reach a lot more people that
haven't read the comic and to introduce
this to new people it it was our biggest
challenge I think one of the things is
that it's also a tricky thing where you
want to make sure the fans of the comics
love the transition but you also have to
expand to you know people that have
never read the comic and make a
television show so talk a little bit
about those challenges and me let's just
I'll stop I think I think my favorite
things about the show there's a few of
them and I think my favorite things
about the show or they kept the weird
ideas they're still there there's some
really heady concepts to get your head
around and the show really stays true to
that and you know that's one of the
things I like the most yeah I think they
kept the essence of the characters they
grabbed that very well and that's what
I'm most proud of and and they have
fresh ideas for everyone and for this
story which are great and fit into the
story and that will add up to the whole
like if we can call it mythology of our
story and that's that's what I think
it's great about this show I'm very
curious when when you're developing
something like this how much is Netflix
and the creators over there saying
what's your five-year plan you know
what's your extended plan and how much
is it sort of like okay let's just come
up with a great idea
season right and then let's see what
happens um they do want to know where
it's heading you know and so what we did
when we began the whole process I was
talking to Steve Blackman the showrunner
and what I did for Steve and for the
writers in that first writers room was
to create them about an 18 page document
that laid everything out even if the
graphic novels that have them coming out
come out again and which should equal
eight when we're all done so I give them
the blueprint for what happens because
you know you do want to seed certain
things in there for future series and
you know the hope is that it's a success
or you get to do a lot more of these so
I think everybody's always kind of key
and they're always curious as to what
Gabrielle and I are doing next we send
them we always send them the new comics
and they really want to know what's
happening that's it
obviously a lot of creators like to
sometimes do like Easter eggs where
they're walking by a seam and like
you're in it but you're not really
pushing yourselves did you visit set
when they were filming did you try to
yourselves in the background of the
scene we visited the set first week but
we weren't ever on the on the screen
you know I've become a little camera shy
yeah I did yeah I'm camera shy as well
not a rock star but I I did some some
work for the series there are in it and
I think you know fans of the comic will
enjoy it when they see it so that's the
only kind of appearance that I did what
my last thing for you guys what's really
cool is there's a lot of mystery when
you start the show starts and you are
trying to just catch up and figure out
what's going on can you sort of talk
about that aspect yeah I you know Mike
Richardson from Dark Horse his favorite
thing and he always said to me about
Umbrella Academy was that it was like
this mystery box that keeps opening and
unfolding and unfolding and that's kind
of what Umbrella Academy is like right
away you're just thrust into this
mystery of like okay well all these
women weren't pregnant before but all of
a sudden they all had babies and
and and then we'll okay number six died
well how did he die we don't we don't
tell you yet and so how does Gabriela I
tell this story and it keeps going on
and on and on that's how we learn about
stuff the more we read the more we learn
we don't know all the backstory we don't
know all the secrets and so these
secrets are revealed over time
you